walk us through the history of taxes
i don't know how far back you can go but
specifically in the states
walk us through how taxes began why it
became you know
started and where we are today how much
more complex it is today versus what it
was
in 1930 13 when it first got started
so so remember in 1913 it was only a tax
on surplus income
it wasn't tax on all income it was
really a tax on what they called excess
earnings
and it really only applied to the very
wealthiest people
around 1944 they changed the law to
apply to employees but even then they
exempted
a living wage so basically the standard
deduction the personal exemptions
they were intended to exempt a living
wage
so that only the excess earnings again
were taxed
and then in the 1960s we started to see
some tax increases and we started to see
um we started to see incentives you know
we had the 1954 act which was a major
tax act
um it was supposed to simplify it then
it complexified things
then we had the 1986 act which supposed
to simplify again
which is what it really did was broaden
the base
so it made more things taxable added
more complexity
what we have now is we actually have a
lower tax rate than we've had
in many many years in the u.s
at one point it was upwards of 90 on the
highest rates
and uh there's all sorts of shenanigans
going on to get out of those right
those kind of 90 taxes so right now you
know we're in that 40
range which is actually kind of a sweet
spot for governments they find that if
people
are paying more than 40 they have a huge
incentive to get out of taxes and if
they pay
much less than 40 percent um the
difference between a lot less than 40
and 40 percent doesn't impact behavior a
whole lot so
what the government really started doing
back in the early 60s with the
investment tax credit
was to kind of test the waters
and see what would happen if we gave a
tax incentive they finally realized
people hate paying taxes right
so if we give a little tax incentive
what will that
change behavior and what they found was
yeah and in fact
it changes behavior the right incentive
will change behavior in a massive way
so really what taxes have become is a
way for the
government to leverage government funds
instead of the government building
houses
for example they encourage uh private
industry to build houses
and as a result um private industry does
10 times the work
for the same number of dollars because
they're getting rewarded through profits
and then when they make the profits
they're also paying the government so
the government wins
multiple times with these incentives so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you